in famous peut tuer une feuille diouf
peut conduire à des exactions et à des
choses terribles
donc ce n'est pas du tout un phénomène à
prendre à la légère
[Musique]
je
génial
une fête nous c'est une fausse
information qui peut être diffusé dans
le but de
nuire à quelqu'un c'est à dire
intentionnellement on comprend à travers
cette exposition qu'il existe une
multiplicité de choses sous ce vocable
faits qui nous il y à des informations
qui ont été spécifiquement fabriqué pour
tromper pour faire de la désinformation
et on le voit aussi des choses plus
humoristique
ben oui on peut essayer de faire rire
quelqu'un avec défectueuse et on ne
connaît pas toujours finalement
l'intention des personnes qui véhiculent
une réflexion et ça concourt finalement
à tromper un maximum de personnes au
final et c'est assez dérangeant en
termes de compréhension de l'information
de compréhension du monde dans lequel on
vit
[Musique]
elles ont toujours en réalité été un
outil politique on peut trouver des
traces de ça dans toute l'histoire du
monde donc ça a toujours été ça a
toujours été un enjeu dans des conflits
dans des dans des luttes d'influencé
notamment des luttes pour le pouvoir
[Musique]
dans mon oeuvre cherche à questionner le
visiteur de l'exposition doit-on ont
fermé ces personnes qui vont propager
des faits que nous
ou au contraire est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
pas éduquer la population à pourvoir
lire décrypter une fausse information
[Musique]
pour remédier contre la propagation des
fausses nouvelles je dirais qu'il est
assez vain de chercher à vérifier toutes
les fausses nouvelles je pense qu'au
contraire il faut travailler les choses
un petit peu plus en amont dans la vie
des citoyens
peut-être au moment
l'éducation avec ce qu'on appelle
l'éducation aux médias
[Musique]